wortschatz
das gehör
hören hören
ich will wirklich nicht die musik so
laut
ich höre dich nicht
die musik ist so laut
ich höre nichts du sprichst zu leise ich
höre nichts du sprichst zu leibe
liebes tagebuch
heute habe ich im wald
das lied eines rotkehlchens gehört
liebes tagebuch
heute habe ich im wald das lied eines
rotkehlchens gehört
als ich die große halle betrat hörte ich
ein seltsames knarren
der geruchssinn
riechen
dieser kuchen riecht sehr gut
duften durften
diese blumen duften wunderbar
schnuppern
der lemur hat zuerst am obst
geschnuppert und dann hat er es gegessen
stinken
dieser müll stinkt ch
dieser müll stinkt sehr
oh nein
diese steak ist schlecht geworden
was für ein schlechter geruch
der geschmack der geschmack
schmecken
dieser kuchen schmeckt sehr gut
süß
dieser kuchen schmeckt süß
scharf
dieses gericht ist wirklich scharf
[Musik]
unser schiff ist online
schau dir unsere tollen produkte ein
besucher unsere anwaltschaft den link in
der infobox
sauer sauer
ihr geht wie ekelig igitt wie ekelig
dieser wein ist sauer
bt bt
wie trinkst du deinen kaffee wie trinkst
du deinen kaffee
peter kein zucker danke bitte kein
zucker danke
wie max du café wie max du café ich mag
bitteren kaffee
ich mag bitteren kaffee
das tasten das tasten
anfassen
anfassen fast den topf nicht an du
verbringst dich
fast den topf nicht an du verbringst
dich ich mag diese jacke nicht sie fasst
sich rau an
ich mag diese jacke nicht sie fasst sich
rau an
was deine hände gut bevor du die pizza
anfasst
geht
dieser pilz fasst sich schleimig an
streicheln darf ich deine katze
streicheln deine katze hat so ein
weiches fell darf ich deine katze
weiches fell
anrühren
du hast das essen nicht angerührt geht
es dir nicht gut
die höhe die höhe
habe ich dir jemals gesagt
dass ich höhenangst habe
ich leide an schwindel
habe ich dir jemals gesagt dass ich
höhenangst habe
ich leide an schwindel
kalt kalt mir ist kalt mir ist kalt ich
bin zu leicht angezogen
mir ist kalt ich bin zu leicht angezogen
ich hätte wärmere klamotten anziehen
sein
darf ich das fenster schließen
es ist kalt darf ich das fenster
schließen es ist kalt
heiß heiß
mir ist heiß mir ist heiß
ich habe mich zu warm angezogen
si
liebes kannst du das fenster öffnen
es ist so heiß heute
kannst du das fenster öffnen es ist so
heiß heute
schmerz fühlen
out
was für rückenschmerzen
was für ein schmerz was für ein schmerz
ich habe mir in den finger geschnitten
wenn euch das video gefallen hat gibt
bitte einen daumen nach oben
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
kleine glocke
klickt ihr um ein weiteres video der
halo deutsche schule